mein name ist mitunter bei den anschlags
ich bin 32 jahre alt kommen aus hamburg
bin eigentlich leichter habhaft werden
durch durch
also für mich ist fussball gucken was
sehr besonderes insbesondere hsv gucken
ist das schönste auf der welt meiner
meinung nach was man zum fußball geht
glückshormone haben wir wollen wir zu
gucken
leider in den letzten jahren nicht so
oft aber was
in erster linie ist die schadenfreude so
groß weil der hsv die letzten zwei
ligaspiele glaube ich mal vorbei
geschrammt ist aber durch ein
unentschieden und ein mal durch die
andere geschichte haben wir alle in
karlsruhe hier gehen nummer 20 doch ist
unklar
mass of hallen sind in der nummer aber
die hoffnung stirbt zuletzt
uns ist natürlich auch klar dass die
meisten spieler einfach nur wegen knete
hier sind wo wir stehen hinter dem
verein
deshalb regt man sich auch so auf weil
die spieler kommen gehe in den verträgen
umgehen wieder aber den scherbenhaufen
der muss irgendwann auf jeden fall so
der hsv ohne entlastung und mit fehlern
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]